Indonesia es un país famoso por tener al
presidente más heavy del mundo.
Y lo digo en serio.
El señor Joko Widodo es bien conocido por
ser un auténtico fanático del heavy metal.
Incluso los mismísimos Judas Priest le invitaron
públicamente a un concierto.
Sólo con esto ya se ha ganado varios puntos
en VisualPolitik.
Pero hay algo más.
Porque no os equivoquéis, por muy fan que
sea de los Judas, a Widodo o, como se le conoce
en el país, JOKOWI, no le gusta nada eso
del “breaking the law”.
Atentos a la noticia.
El presidente Indonesio paga 800 dólares
por un regalo de Metálica
Lo importante de esta noticia no es que a
Widodo le guste METALLICA.
Lo realmente importante es que haya pagado
800 dólares de su propio bolsillo por el
regalo.
Veréis, cuando eres presidente de un país,
es normal que recibas en tu palacio a grandes
personalidades: políticos, intelectuales
y, por supuesto, artistas.
En estos casos, el protocolo dice que el invitado
tiene que hacerte un regalo simbólico: obras
de arte, antigüedades o, en este caso, una
edición rara del Master of Puppets.
Como os podéis imaginar, estos regalos pueden
generar conflictos de intereses.
Por eso, en casi todos los países del mundo,
hay leyes que prohíben que los políticos
se los queden.
Normalmente, estos regalos se los queda el
Estado y, en muchos casos, se guardan en museos
para que la gente los pueda visitar.
En este caso, a Widodo le hacía mucha ilusión
tener ese disco de Metallica.
Y, siendo el presidente, podría haberse saltado
la ley sin problemas.
Sin embargo, decidió hacerlo legalmente y
compró el disco al Estado Indonesio.
Si esto ocurriera en otro país, no nos llamaría
la atención.
Pero en Indonesia, los políticos honestos
son algo nunca visto.
Como veremos más adelante, Indonesia ha tenido
los políticos más corruptos de la historia.
Y creedme, no es ninguna exageración.
Estoy diciendo, literalmente, que el líder
más corrupto de la historia fue uno de sus
ex presidentes.
Y esto explica por qué el pasado mes de abril,
85 millones de indonesios le volvieron a votar
para un segundo mandato.
Jokowi es toda una revolución para Indonesia.
Y no hablamos de un país cualquiera.
Se trata del país más poblado de todo el
mundo musulmán, con más de 255 millones
de habitantes.
Pero, sin duda alguna, la mayor apuesta de
Widodo es esta noticia.
Bienvenidos a la jungla: Indonesia escoge
lugar para su nueva capital
Efectivamente, Indonesia ha anunciado que
cambiará de capital en 2024.
Noticias así no se producen todos los días
pero ¡Eh!
¡Tampoco os vengáis arriba!
No es la primera vez que ocurre algo así.
Ahí están Brasil, Nigeria o Kazajistán,
que también han cambiado de capital en las
últimas décadas.
Sin embargo el cambio de capital en Indonesia,
tiene mucho que contar.
Los que seguís VisualPolitik desde hace tiempo
ya recordaréis este vídeo en el que Couto
os hablaba del despegue de Indonesia.
Entonces os hablábamos de cómo este país
aspiraba a convertirse en la nueva superpotencia
musulmana.
Tras décadas de dictaduras y gobiernos que
lideran todos los rankings de corrupción,
Indonesia está empezando a hacer las cas
bien.
Widodo podrá gustar más o menos, vale.
Pero, por el momento, no tiene ningún escándalo
de corrupción a sus espaldas.
Y, creedme, en un país como Indonesia eso
es casi un milagro.
Jokowi está utilizando los recursos de Indonesia
para solucionar los problemas de los indonesios.
Así que la pregunta es ¿Por qué Widodo
quiere que Yakarta deje de ser la capital
de Indonesia?
¿Tiene sentido llevarse la capital a la jungla
o es un capricho del presidente?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas, pero
antes, vamos a ver un poco de Historia.
YAKARTA, LA CIUDAD HUNDIDA
Cambiar la capital de una ciudad a otra es
algo que me toca muy personalmente ¿Por qué?
Pues porque, por si no lo sabéis, yo soy
de Valladolid, en España.
Por cierto, un abrazo a todos los pucelanos
que me estéis viendo.
Y muchos pensaréis ¿Valladolid?
¿Eso… dónde está?
Y, resulta que Valladolid fue la capital de
España durante 6 años.
Esto fue a principios del siglo XVII.
Y ¿Por qué, os preguntaréis?
Pues por un pelotazo urbanístico.
En aquel momento, el Duque de Lerma, que era
algo así como el Presidente del Gobierno
de aquel entonces, se dedicó a comprar terrenos
y palacios en mi ciudad.
Y para revalorizarlos, convenció el Rey de
que trasladara la capital a Valladolid.
De la noche a la mañana, todas esas propiedades
multiplicaron su valor ¿Y qué hizo el Duque
de Lerma en ese momento?
¡Exacto!
¡Venderlo todo y convertirse en el hombre
más rico de España!
6 años después, repitió la operación en
Madrid.
Y ahí es cuando Madrid pasó a convertirse
en la capital de España.
Como veis, hay cosas en nuestra querida piel
de toro que nunca han cambiado.
Pero este no es el único ejemplo histórico.
Filadelfia y Nueva York fueron capitales de
Estados Unidos mientras se construía de la
nada Washington D.C., que fue una ciudad creada
para ser la sede del Gobierno.
Y lo mismo ocurrió con San Petesburgo, que
la construyó un zar para que fuera la capital
de Rusia durante siglos.
Pero volvamos a Indonesia.
En el año 1949, Indionesia se independizó
de los Países Bajos.
Y pronto se dieron cuenta de que tenían un
problema.
Fijaos en el mapa.
Indonesia está formado por más de 17.000
islas ¡Habéis oído bien!
Y, para que os hagáis una idea, entre Papúa,
que está aquí, y Aceh, que es la isla más
occidental, hay más de 5000 kilómetros de
distancia.
Además, tienen más de 260 millones de habitantes.
En otras palabras, que es un país casi imposible
de gobernar.
Como os podéis imaginar, Indonesia necesita
unas infraestructuras carísimas para conectar
sus islas.
Y no las tiene ¿Conclusión?
Que casi toda la población se concentra en
la Isla de Java y, más concretamente, en
la capital, Yakarta.
El centro político y económico del país.
¿Y qué pasa cuando una ciudad crece sin
control y no hay dinero para construir nuevas
carreteras, ni redes de alcantarillado?
Pues pasa esto…
Yakarta desperdicia 5.000 millones de dólares
cada año por los atascos
Pensadlo bien, a día de hoy hay más de 30
millones de personas viviendo en el área
metropolitana de Yakarta.
Y, como el Ayuntamiento no ha construido redes
de saneamiento, el 30% de las familias no
tienen agua corriente en sus casas.
Así que ¿Qué hacen para beber agua?
Pues construir pozos ilegales.
Esto tiene dos problemas: por un lado, el
agua que sale de esos pozos es más turbia
que los libros de cuentas de Odebrecht pero
es que, por el otro lado, genera un problema
ambiental de primer nivel.
Podríamos decir que los yakarteses están
con el agua al cuello.
Literalmente.
Yakarta, la ciudad que más rápido se hunde
en el mundo
Veréis, Yakarta se erigió en un terreno
pantanoso en el que confluyen hasta 13 ríos.
Ahora se está hundiendo unos 15 centímetros
cada año.
La mitad de Yakarta ya está por debajo del
nivel del mar.
Y su población va a seguir creciendo.
Para que os hagáis una idea, se espera que
dentro de 10 años tenga más población que
Tokio.
¿Y cuál es la solución para evitar este
desastre?
Pues nuestro amigo Widodo lo tiene claro:
cambiar la capital.
Puede parecer una locura pero tiene bastante
lógica.
Pensadlo bien, si movemos todas las instituciones
a otra ciudad, también se mudarán todos
los funcionarios que trabajan en ella, y con
ellos, todos los empleos indirectos.
¿El problema?
Que una mudanza de este estilo es extremadamente
cara.
Se trata de construir una macrociudad desde
0.
Y la pregunta es ¿Tiene Indonesia el dinero
suficiente para acometer semejante inversión?
Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
EL LEGADO DE JOKOWI
Sí.
Gobernar Indonesia es muy complicado.
Ahora bien, hay un motivo por el que si jugarais
al Age of Empires siempre querríais ser Indonesia.
Y es que, amigos de VisualPolitik, cuando
se repartieron las materias primas, este archipiélago
quedó muy bien parado.
Oro, petróleo, gas, madera, papel...
¡Vamos!
Que no tienen una perspectiva tan mala.
Pero ¿Cuál es el riesgo de tener tanta riqueza
natural?
Pues que muchas veces, toda esa riqueza se
queda en manos del dictador corrupto de turno.
En este caso hablamos de Sukarno, el padre
de la patria.
Estuvo dos décadas en el poder.
Y terminó siendo uno de los hombres más
ricos del mundo.
Tras él llegó el general Suharto.
¿Y qué creéis que hizo durante sus 30 años
de dictadura militar?
Pues, básicamente Suharto suhartó a robar.
De hecho, también terminó convirtiéndose
en uno de los hombres más ricos del mundo.
Mirad esta portada de la revista Time en 1999.
Suharto Sociedad Limitada.
¿Cómo construyó una fortuna familiar el
mandamás de Indonesia?
Hablamos de un saqueo de más de 15.000 millones
de dólares.
De hecho, en 2004, transparencia internacional
hizo un ranking con los políticos más corruptos
de todos los tiempos y Suharto se llevó el
premio.
Vamos, que a su lado, Fujimori o Duvalier
son un político danés.
Y, como os podéis imaginar, todo ese dinero
que iba a los bolsillos de los políticos
es dinero que no se invertía en infraestructuras
básicas.
Así que ¿Qué ha pasado cuando los políticos
indonesios han dejado de robar?
Pues cosas tan increíbles como esta.
Mirad que derroche de innovación llegó a
Indonesia el marzo de 2019.
Y sí, esta noticia es de 2019.
El primer metro de Indonesia abre en Yakarta,
ahogada por el tráfico
30 años ha tardado el metro en hacerse realidad
desde que se planificó.
¿Y sabéis cuál ha sido el factor decisivo
para que, por fin, una de las ciudades más
pobladas del mundo tenga metro?
Dos palabras; JOKO WIDODO.
Con Joko Widodo como gobernador de Yakarta
comenzaron las obras hace 6 años y con Joko
Widodo como presidente de Indonesia se han
terminado.
Y de hecho esto es el pilar de su gobierno:
infraestructuras.
Un megaplan de construcción de infraestructuras
por todo el país cifrado en más de 300.000
millones de dólares.
Y cuando hablamos de un archipiélago dominado
por la jungla, os aseguro que no es un capricho.
Más de 3.000 kilómetros de ferrocarriles
y otros tantos de carreteras.
Puertos marítimos y aeropuertos.
Muchos trayectos se han reducido a un tercio
del tiempo que requerían antes.
Imaginad una mercancía que antes necesitara
3 horas para hacer un desplazamiento muy sencillo
y ahora se tarde menos de 60 minutos.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque hay algo
que falta en el esta fórmula!
La inversión privada.
Como os podéis imaginar, un plan tan ambicioso
como este necesita mucho dinero.
Y la ayuda privada es muy importante.
Eso explica que, por mucho que Widodo prometiera
un crecimiento del 7% anual, Indonesia sólo
ha crecido al 5%.
Es decir, que en lo que a crecimiento se refiere,
Indonesia todavía sigue como estaba con los
presidentes corruptos.
Y diréis ¿Por qué no hay inversión privada?
Pues lo cierto es que Indonesia es un país
extremadamente hermético.
Una empresa extranjera solamente puede instalarse
en Indonesia si antes se asocia con una compañía
local.
Y muchos sectores todavía permanecen en manos
de las empresas estatales.
Por eso actualmente la inversión extranjera
apenas supone un 1,5% del PIB de Indonesia.
Una cifra muy baja respecto a otros países
asiáticos.
Pero también tenemos que añadir el factor
trabajo.
La indemnización por despido en Indonesia
es la tercera más alta del mundo.
Y los sueldos en este país son un 45% más
altos que en países vecinos como Vietnam.
Y, mientras tanto, el Gobierno sigue empeñazo
en echar a cualquier potencial inversor con
noticias como esta.
La mayor mina de oro del mundo es nacionalizada
en Indonesia
Y todo esto son malas noticias porque Indonesia
va a necesitar muchísima inversión si quiere
cambiar de capital.
Actualmente la isla de Java, que es donde
está Yakarta, concentra el 60% del PIB de
Indonesia.
Y la isla de Borneo, donde se construirá
la nueva capital, apenas el 8%.
Cambiar la capital de isla va a ser el gran
legado de nuestro amigo Jokowi.
Pero también es un reto de proporciones nachovidalianas.
El Gobierno cifra en 33.000 millones de dólares
el coste de levantar una nueva capital en
la jungla.
Esto es el coste de 2 juegos olímpicos.
Y Widodo ya ha dicho que el Estado sólo puede
aportar el 20%.
El otro 80% tiene que venir de manos privadas.
Y las manos privadas no van a interesarse
en esta inversión si no cambian la legislación.
Así que, ahora la pregunta es para vosotros
¿Qué os parece el cambio de capital que
propone Jokowi?
¿Creéis que Indonesia podrá modernizarse?
Y también ¿Os gustaría cambiar la capital
de vuestro país?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Mientras tanto, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
a VisualPolitik y dadle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.